a
[Música]
bueno
74 días en malvinas
un hecho que por supuesto movilizó a
todo nuestro país y a vos también y
quiero y queremos saber qué fue lo que
más te movilizó de todo lo que fue en
guerra de malvinas
sin dudas
el primer ataque del primero de mayo
este
ese día cayeron
21 bombas de 500 kilos cada una
y en cinco segundos nos cambió la vida
porque incluso eran con retardo de decir
que explotaban unas unas horas después
también
e
y recuerdo que estaba de guardia
justo a las 4 y 40 aproximadamente de la
madrugada una noche cerrada anulada
y sentimos
un avión incluido de motores de avión
y eso nos produjo una confusión porque
no sabíamos si era nuestro o enemigo
porque los nuestros venían al ras del
agua a aterrizar el aeropuerto y éste
venía a un alto superior entonces éste
de pronto arroja todas esas bombas
y bueno no dejo
nos movió todo
en mi caso me paralizó el corazón porque
realmente son las bombas que destruyen
todo y entonces este bueno no solamente
por lo que genera la bomba en sí la
destrucción total de lo que cada donde
cae sino lo que genera en cada uno de
nosotros lo que generó en mi caso
de género inseguridad temor
y muerte también porque a la mañana
siguiente a la mañana digamos nos dice
informan que había habían hecho varios
destrozos en el aeropuerto y que había
caído un soldado de nuestra compañía
alcanzado por las esquirlas entonces
éste
eso nos produjo una sensación de pasar
de joven a hombre en un instante claro
porque no imaginaban primero que iban a
malvinas eso en primer momento y llegar
a lugares y decir esto no era un juego
de niños sino todo lo contrario no no se
terminó se terminó la aventura que uno
iba imagina que te daban un fusil
cargadores casco pistolas de bote
sentías superhéroe porque ellos quien me
va a hacer algo con todo esto es decir
18 o 19 años este sentirse fuerte con
todo eso y bueno con ese bombardeo algo
se terminó en nosotros empezamos a
digamos tener una responsabilidad
totalmente distinta a la que veníamos
teniendo
y en ese momento a que se aferraban por
qué es tan difícil estar en bajo esa
situación esa presión que la muerte está
ahí al lado entonces es algo a que te
esperabas la oración la oración a dios
el resto del rosario ahí aprendí a rezar
el rosario lo habíamos aprendido
mientras habíamos llegado en los días
anteriores al ataque
incluso resolvamos todos juntos
y después del ataque lo tuvimos que
hacer de a 2 de a 3 nada más porque cada
uno ya después estaba en su posición no
se podía mover estaba de guardia todo el
tiempo
dormíamos poco pero el resto fue algo
muy importante para nosotros porque
me parece pasión me pasó algo muy muy
lindo porque yo cuando rezaba el rosario
yo sabía que mi mamá mi madre lo rezaba
también esa conexión que tenías con
exactamente era era algo fortalecedor
cuando volví y yo le conté que rezaba y
ella me decía que ella rezaba más que yo
una especie de competencia sanamente sí
pero fue fue muy bueno muy lindo en ese
momento tan difícil
y las cartas que nosotros cuando tenemos
nuestra historia y los escuchamos a
ustedes
recibiste las pudiste leer contestaste
alguna de ellas no llegaron
una de un jardín de infantes algo muy
tierno decir tierno en medio de la
guerra pero es difícil pero mismo
se necesitaba en ese momento pero una
carta que dibujada por unos chicos de
jardín de infantes donde dibujan un
soldado con la bandera argentina en las
islas defendiendo decir estamos con
ustedes es decir era realmente muy
especial también alguien anónimo que
decía suerte como el nombre que se o
verónica es decir que ustedes no sabían
de quién en el territorio argentino que
los acompañaba para nada y eso bueno
comer un chocolate
en plena guerra en pleno bombardeo bueno
podríamos ser otra cosa no sabes lo que
se siente
no sabes lo que es en un momento me
acordaba del viaje a bariloche que había
hecho un año antes de decir y uno está
acá ahora decir algo muy lógico todo lo
que nos pasaba y bueno este igual que el
cigarrillo cuando fuma vamos
resumamos imagínate unos alcanzaban para
compartir lo poco que había porque
recordamos que escaseaba la comida es
todo
los fumamos y hacía cuenta que alguien
estaba con nosotros acompañándonos que
había venido del continente eso así que
todo eso lo realmente lo sentimos así y
después bueno
en ese en esos días también recibo una
carta de un familiar
una carta muy importante más allá de
todo lo que me cuenta me mandó una carta
aparte donde me manda algo para que yo
tenga y lea
que fue un pilar para mí que fue el
salmo 91 bueno eso me ayudó muchísimo a
mí
bueno y después este después cuando
y mediados de mayo mandó una carta mandó
una carta a mi familia tranquilizando
los tratando de decir que bueno que todo
va a salir bien que me cuido que se
queden tranquilos que extraño todo
extrañaba la cama el patio el perro mi
familia los amigos obviamente uno
esperaba que se solucionen pacíficamente
todo pero no cada vez teníamos noticias
más fuerte más duras
lógicamente estar en malvinas es un
hecho que que t-mobile hizo pero cuál
fue de todo lo que viviste allá te marcó
para siempre y hoy nos quieres contar
bueno debe haber sido aproximadamente 8
o 10 de junio aproximadamente ya el frío
calaba los huesos y el hambre el
estómago también ya estamos al límite de
nuestras fuerzas entonces se está
decidido
ir a buscar comida a una cocina un lugar
donde saben que están en desgracia no es
exactamente entonces este voy a la
madrugada a la noche y
saco un paquete de masitas de galletitas
y un tarro con dulce de leche eso era
una comida mortal para nosotros te
imaginas porque no lo compartíamos entre
lo que podíamos
y entonces cuando salgo me encuentro con
el oficial
y durante la sorpresa de ambos me dice
que está haciendo el soldado mira buscar
comida
y entonces saca su arma y me la pone en
la cabeza y me dices mañana va a tener
su merecido me saca me saca de la
trinchera de mi trinchera
y me saca el arma y me da una pala me
voy a llevar a digamos a las playas
entre el mar y las trincheras me hace a
cavar un pozo de metro y medio
aproximadamente hasta acá lo que ir a
enterrar mira no sabías y yo era el
objetivo
me hizo meter en el pozo y estuve así
aproximadamente 24 horas un poco más
socialmente se te veía en la cabeza así
sí
en total estado de soledad y abandono
ese era un poco el castigo o la tortura
que hacían
por robar comida o sacar comida
debidamente no esté bueno allí comienza
algo una transformación en mí es decir
primero yo me tuve que fortalecer
diciéndome a mí mismo que bueno que yo
voy a pagar este error que yo voy a
salir de acá yo digo 24 horas personas
sabía que era 24 horas no sabía es el
tiempo más puede haber sido más si puede
hacer
porque ahí ya no teníamos idea de la
obra nada tenía el día nada pero por eso
bueno eso fue lo que me motivó a mí
para sobreponerme para decir bueno me
voy a aferrar
al salmo 91 me voy a aferrar al rosario
y me voy a aferrar a mis sueños y a mis
proyectos
de ahí en más fue el único que me motivó
fue lo que me llevó adelante a seguir
sobrevivirás sobre ir sobrevivir
exactamente decía pensaba en cosas
lindas en cosas positivas yo voy a salir
de acá peor que esto no voy a estar ahí
sentí miedo por segunda vez porque
estaba desarmado no podía ni defenderme
yo ni defender a mis compañeros
y algo ilógico queda en la guerra
el castigo y entonces este bueno
a medianoche viene algo que realmente me
conmovió bien un compañero arrastrándose
un poco así escondiéndose de que no lo
vea el oficial y me trae un jarro de
sopa y me lo trae y yo no lo podía creer
mi hijo después me dijo porque no sabía
si le ayuda a pasar yo también pensaba
bueno en lo que él había hecho se la
jugó por mí
entonces eso me fortaleció es decir la
guerra nos unió también en esas cosas
por ejemplo así que si hubiese pasado de
louis en mucho lo mismo
entonces este bueno de allí empiezo a
pensar ya de cosas positivas
digo yo bueno este no me puede estar
yendo tan mal entonces bueno empecé a
pensar en cosas buenas positivo y cuando
fue el momento que te sacaron del pozo
bueno salvo a la mañana no sé qué hora
eran cerca el mediodía del día siguiente
y me saca del pozo y me devuelve la
difícil
y bueno que vaya de nuevo a la posición
a la trinchera
ya no era el mismo soldado
pero era un hombre que enfrentó durante
más de 24 horas en un lugar con tanta
desolación y tanta adversidad para salir
un hombre para cumplir sus proyectos
pero si sucedió algo también con el
famoso pin de trinchera exactamente
cuando salí no sentía mis pies no podía
ni caminar porque no lo sentí los pies
eso que sentís hinchado que de trinchera
se llama entumecido es decir que no lo
sentís por el enfriamiento permanente es
decir nunca lo pudimos calentar ni en
las trincheras y menos menos estando
allí en ese pozo y nunca lo pudimos
calentar con nada así que te imaginas
que estaba al borde ya de no sentir y
eso es muy grave no sentir los pies
porque después viene ya la cangrena y
etcétera etcétera y te pusieron las
botas y te dirán que con exactamente
cuando salgo de allí no no no no sentía
mis pies entonces me saco de los
cordones desató los cordones de mis
zapatos de nuevo por seguir entonces me
trae un par de botas de los cuales no me
podían entrar no entraban porque yo
tenía los pies duros
entonces cortamos la bota por los
costados y con los cordones del borceguí
y los gatos y así pude andar los últimos
días sé que eran faltaban 34 días para
terminar todo porque después
sabía que era había sido en esos días
por eso no no no tengo bien precisó el
día 74 días y llegó el regreso cómo fue
ese fin y ese regreso
caminando cuando recibimos la
información de que se había rendido el
gobernador
en ese momento de las islas sentí dos
sensaciones encontradas
primero sobre mucho lloré hasta
desahogarme por todo lo que hicimos
y después bueno me sentí un poco
aliviado porque sabía que la guerra
había terminado y que iba a volver a
casa sano y salvo tales así como como
rezábamos inconscientemente con la
conexión que hacía con mi madre y
entonces esté caminando hacia puerto
argentino entregar las armas eso fue
algo muy doloroso fue asegurar que fue
algo muy de los de haber tenido tu arma
durante tanto tiempo que era parte de tu
cuerpo el arma si se convertía en la
defensa también que tenía exactamente
pero bueno no abandoné nunca el rosario
lo tuve siempre y ese era mi arma yo
creo que el rosario fue el arma más
fundamental que el arma de 100.000 se
emite en sí mismo así que eso me
fortaleció mucho cuando fuimos a
entregar las armas yo entregué la arma
pero yo tenía la otra arma
que me va a permitir seguir adelante
eso fue muy doloroso en silencio la
verdad todos los soldados que fuimos a
entregar la sala estábamos muy muy que
no sabía qué había pasado
bueno como prisionero de los ingleses
estuvimos 45 días cuando de toman
prisioneros no sabes que van a hacer con
vos
pero no puedo decir mucho porque no nos
trataron bien
y bueno este
cuando cuando el 20 de junio a las 3 de
la tarde nos embargan en el buque el
almirante irízar ahí sentí un poco que
ya estaba más en casa porque sabía que
era nuestro el buque
bueno y somos el continente
y bueno fui recibido por los familiares
y muchos no pudieron hacer eso muchos
fueron escondidos y eso es algo que
apuntó que hasta el día de hoy
desde ese momento se produjo la
desmalvinización y que corre por estos
días todavía
y como mensaje final que nos queremos
dejar hoy
bueno primero que la guerra extrema las
proezas y las miserias humanas
en eso hubo muchos malvinas en
situaciones límites hay personas que
sacan lo mejor de sí y hay otras que se
sacan lo peor de sí
eso lo experimenté en malvinas
segundo yo perdone sinceramente de
corazón al oficial que me hizo ese
castigo
porque no quise cargar con ninguna
mochila de rencor ni nada es algo que lo
sentía así que me hizo muy bien el
personal te libera de saná de cura
tenéis que perdonar aunque te cueste y
segundo y tercero bueno fuimos
a defender nuestras islas malvinas
porque
nos enseñaron en la escuela que son
nuestras
y fuimos sin pedir nada a cambio
y como mensaje final
me gustaría que
[Música]
cumplan sus sueños que sueñen
que tengan proyectos y que luchen por
ellos
porque te hace sentir vivo
como me tocó a mí
muchas gracias
[Música]
y